your Pearson what is the origin of the
title of your book the shadow of the
Panther it originates out of my
determination to find a good title the
cached attention of publishing houses
when I became a proposal and also well
you know that's one part the other part
is I wanted to explain you know the
nature what I would wanted to do was
like the the shadow of the Panther what
kind of legacy did the Black Panther
Party leave America with in general in
black America with in particular and I
thought that it would it would be a good
title to use to convey what I was trying
to say about the Black Panther Party so
that picture on the covers of Huey
Newton and that the the subtitlers Huey
Newton and the price of black power in
America who was you noon you renewed
Huey Newton was the he's called the
co-founder who's actually the founder
and driving force behind the Black
Panther Party he founded the party in
the fall of 1966 he and Bobby Seale
actually founded the party but Bobby
Seale was more public relations a person
along with Eldridge Cleaver and Newton
was really the driving force the real
power behind everything I think that the
Black Panther Party is an organization
that it without question that got its
start kind of coming out of what had
been started by the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee so I think the
Huey Newton is definitely a person who
had two sides as I pointed out the book
the one side of him was a criminal kind
of you know very criminal from the very
beginning petty criminal and then it
became much more serious later on but
the other side was an intellectual
intellectual something that I think you
don't see a combination or see too often
in african-american men anymore it would
almost be like Tupac Shakur a person who
was in the news for a while you know as
engaging about so all sorts of
outrageous activities along with his rap
someone like Tupac who could quote the
philosophers and writers from all over
the world and also speak English
properly Huey Newton was very much
personally that but at the same time
could go down on the streets and and
and get in a fight and beat up anybody
did patchily and when he come across or
engage in criminality with anyone a kid
you write the Tupac Shakur's mother was
a black panther I didn't write that but
his mother was a black male I think I
did refer to her to her in the book yeah
I referred to her because she was in the
New York Chapter of the Black Panthers
um so yeah he he is one of the young
people who speaks of the Black Panthers
almost as as icons so yeah she was in
the party I don't I don't spend much
attention I just spent like a sentence
or two hundred where was Huey Newton
from he was from Oakland California
his family originally came from Monroe
Louisiana he was named after Huey Long
because there's a lot of people who know
anything about southern politics and
Louisiana politics no long was a very
popular populist governor who was very
different from most of the southern
governors of the 1920s and 30s and easil
governor and dinner senator you the most
of the southern politicians in that era
engaged in race baiting politics and
though a case can easily be made that
Huey Long was a racist he did not engage
in race baiting politics he was very
populist in his nature and he had this
you know the whole notion of every man a
king so a lot of blacks in Louisiana had
a respect for that and Huey Newton's
father Walter Newton out of respect for
what long was trying to accomplish for
all poor people in Louisiana decided to
name his son Huey as well you know so so
that's how he got his name right on the
flap opening flap of this book you talk
about August 22nd 1989 what happened
August 22nd 1989 was the day that Huey
Newton approached he went oh he went to
West Oakland he had he'd grown up all
over Oakland and by this time we're
talking about a Newton who had he'd been
in jail he had come out of jail for the
shooting of an officer police officer in
Oakland and it was it was while he was
in jail the Black Panther Party became
the National Party that everybody
remembers because he professed it he did
not kill this officer and we have to
understand that this is 1967 the fall of
1967 you had a number of different
groups who were saw the police as their
enemies
you had the anti-war young whites and
anti-war movement and you had young
blacks
young black militants both of whom said
well the the police are our enemy and
they kind of latched on Huey Newton as a
hero for being accused for of shooting
this police officer so Huey Newton
became just this this icon that
everybody looked up to and when he came
out of jail
on a technicality in 1970 because he had
been convicted of manslaughter when he
came out of jail he was a he he was he
was a person that was celebrated by
radicals everywhere I mean it was it was
the thing to have your anti-war button
on the one hand free Huey button on the
other that your or if you were black
young by pressing your black power
button and along with that you're free
Huey button so Huey came out of that and
came into a celebrity world of limousine
liberals of Hollywood liberals who kind
of latched on to him but at the same
time he developed a very heavy drug
addiction he had always been he had been
a petty criminal and by a petty criminal
I mean a person who engaged in short
chains short change scams in Oakland he
had done that while he was in high
school and on up into his into his early
20s but then when he came out and we
became about a person who was an icon of
the beautiful people he became heavily
addicted to cocaine he had tried drugs
before but not he didn't he did not
become addicted anywhere near to the
extent he became addicted in 1970 when
he came out of prison and he became a
virtual monster in a lot of ways I mean
he just the decide of Huey Newton that
there could be you could engage an evil
activity just it just accelerated
because a cocaine makes a person very
paranoid he engaged a lot of sexual
abuse he engaged in in the ordering
ordering the murder of people within the
party and in the cases of some people
outside the party I mean I have to ask
you how do you know all this because of
out of talking to people who were
actually in the party and out of going
over court records and and and
uncovering the evidence that he actually
engaged in this there's plenty of
evidence around that Huey Newton did he
was accused and in charge was plenty of
killings and accused in charge was
charged with
embezzling money from a school the
Panthers the the Black Panthers had how
many times they convicted of something
he was convicted okay was convicted in
1967 he was convicted of as well of
stabbing Odelle Lee in 1964 this was a
misdemeanor conviction he was convicted
of a very minor charge in about 1987 88
so he was convicted of something
probably about three four times so he
was charged with with a number of
different things since was he and did he
go to jail every time no he didn't go to
jail every time he was he was out on
bail for a long long periods of time
when he he came out of jail in 1970 on
the manslaughter conviction and shooting
the Oakland police officer and he was
tried two times over again and the the
trials resulted in hung jury so he was
be if the case was dismissed go back to
the August 22nd 1989 okay August 22nd
1989 Huey Newton had come out of jail on
a misdemeanor charge was a drug
possession charge by this time we're
talking about a man who's very much
addicted to cocaine his organization no
longer exists no Black Panthers were
practically defunct by 1982 and he come
he's heavily addicted to crack cocaine
so he comes he goes to to West Oakland
and on this particular night that you're
speaking of when he tries to get some
more cocaine because what he's doing is
he's not paying for the cocaine the way
the crack cocaine away most customers
pay and he's he's Bank basically he's
pressuring drug dealers to give him
drugs because you know I'm Huey Newton's
basically his his whole thing is like
I'm Huey Newton I used to be king of the
streets you'd have to really pay respect
to me because of who I am so drug
dealers are giving him money but is this
very complex thing he's the there's an
auger there's organizations who are
running drugs on the streets of Oakland
and one organization is the black
guerrilla family which is prison based
now there are Black Panthers who became
part of the black guerrilla family while
they were in prison because there are a
number of people who are in the Black
Panther Party who end up going to prison
Huey Newton there's a lot of anger
against Huey Newton because
of him abandoning these Panthers while
they were in prison and and uh no longer
allowing the Panther Party to to take
care of them and their families to the
extent that they did before he got out
of prison in 1970 so you have a lot of
residual anger in the bgf resulting from
that as well as the fact that he's he's
taking money from he's taking drugs from
these guys without paying so a contract
is put on the life of Huey Newton and on
this particular August night a young man
decides to - Tyrone Robinson decides to
take up the contract because he thinks
he's gonna move up in the organization
and on that night
he's puts three bullets in the head of
Huey Newton and Huey Newton dies how do
you know that
Tyrone Robinson did it well he was he
was charged with the killing he he was
convicted of second-degree murder I went
to the trial I and I interviewed the
Willie Payne who was actually with Huey
Newton before he died and he is a matter
of fact Huey Newton crossed paths with
will be paying the night that he died
and decided to get the cocaine and come
back to Willie Willie Payne's apartment
and smoked the cocaine I mean yeah the
crack cocaine did you talk to Tyrone
Robinson I didn't I tried to talk to
Tyrone Robinson but I didn't get a
chance to talk title and Robbins at all
I did was hear his testimony and also go
in court and also goes to the court
records and uh because there's a lot of
games were a different police reports
and everything that it was as well as
what I could glean from Willie Payne and
to reconstruct everything did you go to
the funeral hearing I didn't go to the
funeral viewing because I came to
Oakland see he died in August I came to
the Bay Area in November so I didn't get
a chance to go to the funeral what was
your reason for going to the Bay Area
I came to Barry because I had a
tentative offer from Robert Maynard
publishers Oakland Tribune to me to
rifle locum Tribune I say tentative only
because he said well soon as I can open
something up I'd like to have you on my
staff so I was freelancing in New York
City I didn't have anything solid in New
York City because everyone was telling
me it's a major paper as well you know
you have to pay your dues you have to go
out and leave New York and come and work
your way back so I thought Bob Maynard
tentative offer was the best offer that
I had so I decided to come to the Bay
Area and wing it go out to the Bay Area
and I
same timing the Panthers since my birth
name is Huy the Panthers had kind of
left my mind from my childhood because
in my childhood I had read everything
practically everything I get my hands on
about the Panther so when hew he was
killed in August I was like well you
know my goodness what happened to this
guy what happened to the Black Panther
Party I want to investigate what
happened to Black Panther Party as well
as pursue this newspaper opportunity in
the Bay Area so that's what brought me
to the Bay Area did you ever think at
any time of your life you wanted to be a
black panther when I was I would say
when I was about about 10 well I'll say
more 11 12 11 or 12 years old during the
heyday of the Black Panther Party yeah I
thought you know would be great to be a
Black Panther because the most of the
media particularly the media the leftist
community and the liberal community most
of the media gave you the impression of
the Panthers were really great guys who
were coming up with community programs
and that any kind of problems they were
having with the police was because they
were trying to do something good so yeah
I was very much into the Black Power
movement Black Power era when I was 12
11 12 13 years old did you have to be
black to be a member you yeah for the
most part you did have to be black for
your member but a lot of people don't
realize that the Black Panthers were
different than black nationalists the
Black Panthers believe that the system
was at fault for the problems of black
people and poor people in general they
didn't they had a lot of white allies
and that's one of the reasons I think a
lot of the white radical movements like
the SDS The Weather Underground the
Peace and Freedom Party they created
alliances with the Panther Party because
the Panthers said well you know we
believe that this is the system this
that's that's wrong and not white people
in general that is opposed to what
happened and snick now snick started out
as an integrated organization but
eventually the leadership is snick
decided to kick the whites out of the or
out of the organization and you had a
number of different black militant
groups that didn't want to work with
whites get some pictures in here some
people Meyer that will be very familiar
and you mentioned Schneck and I wanted
to hold this picture up right here of
Stokely Carmichael what is Nick and what
did he have to do with it okay well
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee was an organization that
really for the most part started out as
the is
youth branch of Martin Luther King civil
rights movement as everyone is quite
familiar with the story 1955 was the
year when most people chart at the
beginning of the actual nonviolent
resistance to segregation the movement
in which blacks you know decided well
you know we're gonna put our foot down
we're not gonna stand for this anymore
and then you had a lot of young people
like John Lewis Bob Moses James Forman
and the like who decide well you know we
want to do something as well so it
started out very much an alliance with
Martin Luther King and eventually
started veering away from King engaging
in tactics that were were more daring
than what King and his disciples really
wanted them to engage in so eventually
you know it started out out that way you
had the Freedom Rides which basically
started by Korbut which was were
assisted by people in the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee
you went from there went to voter
registration projects and it started out
as an integrated movement and Stokely
Carmichael joined the movement early on
and well basically he went into
Mississippi went to Alabama he was part
of the Freedom Rides and he became more
and more militant now you had other
people in the in snick people like Bob
Moses and John Lewis who didn't become
his militant as Stokely Carmichael
eventually became buddy but he became
more militant and steered snick towards
a militant direction John Lewis the
congressman from the Llano occurred the
current congressman from it'll come back
to Stokely Carmichael for a moment where
is he today Stoney Carmichael's in
Africa right now he was and I believe
visiting Donna for a while but not right
now I'm forgetting the particular
country but it's in West Africa I
believe where he is way enough yeah I
think it's Guinea yeah
there's a hyphen to it I don't know
anybody saw it but he started black
power
the phrase black power what does that
mean he and some of his disciples
started what does that mean basically it
was um it grew out of snicks
dissatisfaction with what had gone in
1964 the Democratic National Convention
that snick in alliance with some people
in Mississippi who creates a Mississippi
Freedom Party went to the Democratic
National Convention having register
anywhere between one to two thousand
black voters and said well look this we
are the true representatives we should
be sitting in representing the state of
Mississippi at the convention and Lyndon
Johnson said well look I need the South
I can't have I can't handle this right
now we'll give you two seats at the
convention he dispatched Humphrey to
tell him we'll give you two seats they
wouldn't accept that so they went if the
following year they went to Alabama to
register voters in a third party effort
and they came up with the black the
notion of black power as a means to
campaign and get black people to see we
need to empower ourselves now eventually
they became because they didn't elect
anybody in this third party effort the
effort through which they came up with a
symbol of the Black Panther and the
reason that came up with the symbol was
because you had a lot of illiterate
blacks and they decided well we have to
figure out a way for these black people
to recognize our ballots so we're gonna
come up with the symbol the Black
Panther so you had the black power the
notion of black car the philosophy of
black power this symbol of the Black
Panther that was even what was initially
used to register poor blacks in the
black garden Alabama in Lowndes County
and that eventually after after the
electoral efforts did not result in
anyone being elected then it was carried
north and it became the notion of black
power empowering ourselves by any means
necessary even if it meant taking up the
gun where's your hometown originally
grew up in Fort Wayne Indiana how long
just lived there for 17 years I go I
will see that's 17 and a half years my
parents what they do my father was a
physician he's still a physician he's 73
years old he has had his own private
practice now he's uh he's the medical
director of our hospital in Fort Wayne
hey goo he originally came from George
only as a matter of fact he's settling
for when only a few weeks before I was
born your mother my mother died when I
was 17 she had a terminal illness for
eight and a half years so she was
originally from Florida she met my
father and when he was in medical school
and she was a nurse at Mary Medical
College in Nashville
what's your father's politics I would
say my father is what could be
classified as conservative you know a
lot of people talk about the black can
you know blacks who are conservative and
I would say he could probably be
classified as conservative mean a very
self-reliant man who who taught his kids
to believe in themselves that they could
do anything they wanted to do they
as good as anybody else but my father is
not a kind of person who had any who
would voice any kind of support for
something like the Black Power movement
brothers sisters I have two sisters one
older and one younger
we're actually three now because I have
a little eight-year-old sister for my
father's third marriage where are you
just I said both over in Atlanta in the
Atlanta area in suburban Atlanta what
was it like growing up in Fort Wayne
Indiana well it was interesting I think
it's my fact I was thinking about this a
few weeks ago
Indiana has basically seen as a pretty
conservative state and I think that
politically that's that's that's a
that's pretty dead-on but growing up
before when I grew up in a small
middle-class black Enclave and I went to
predominantly white schools from the
from the nursery school on up and you
know there were some racial tension but
for the most part there wasn't a whole
lot of racial tension in in a in junior
high and you know in elementary school
junior high in high school and I
basically well first first when I was in
elementary school I didn't do that well
only because I was into the Black Power
movement and some of the some of the
guys I grew up with we all got this
notion in our head they had to do our
school work was becoming like white
people so we didn't want to do our
school work so actually after I fell out
of that in junior high school by reading
David Halberstam book the best of the
brightest and after just started doing
well in school I was basically accepted
by all the other students who did was
good I were there a handful of black
students in my school who did well and
you know of course you had your your
minority of white students you know the
the cream of the crop of the white
students who did well and they basically
accepted me as their peer as a person
who's very intelligent and interestingly
it wasn't until I got to Brown
University in Rhode Island that I even
came across the notion that I might be
inferior because I was black because you
had the affirmative action program and a
lot of whites felt well the only reason
blacks are here is because affirmative
action is giving them a leg up so I
would say growing up in Fort Wayne you
know there's there's a lot of the
cliches around the conservative
Midwestern values
optimistic Midwestern values and I think
that so for the most part those values
it's true I mean there might not be the
worldliness you'll find on the east or
the west coast but those values I think
I think there is something to this
notion of of basic Midwestern values
that I think that
that I was brought up with and in my
notion did please don't you know tell me
tell me be straight with me and don't
don't give me a lot of crap so I think I
grew up with that go back to the David
Halberstam book the best and the
brightest was about it was about Lyndon
Johnson and the Vietnam War actually
Kennedy Johnson and the Vietnam War how
the Unites States became involved in the
war and all of the advisers that they
were part of that and how did that
impact you it impacted me very much
because you had people like McGeorge
Bundy who was very intelligent in course
Johnson himself didn't go to to a
prestigious college but practically
everyone he surrounded himself with and
Kennedy as well of course a lot of the
people that Johnson surrounded himself
with or carryovers from the Kennedy
administration at least initially but
McNamara McGeorge Bundy and people like
that and going to very prestigious
schools and and for some reason the way
hell we're standing wrote this book it
was these men were very fascinating to
me and I thought well you don't she and
I would like to do something similar
what these men are doing not not that I
was interested in engaging in Vietnam
war policy but just the way the book was
written it made it something had very
fascinating minds and and I really
latched on to that and the idea that you
know that it'll be really great to go to
a major very prestigious school an Ivy
League school so in about the 9th grade
I started investigating schools and I I
bought a book I think was the insider's
guide to colleges and I just started
like going through the insider's guide
and saying well what you know what the
different programs at different colleges
were we're all about and browns Brown
University something I had a very
interesting program about a very liberal
program that allowed you to take you
know whatever questions you wanted to
take but also meeting was very creative
and just sounded like a really good
program so Brown was of school I said oh
I'm definitely gonna apply to this
school you know in a couple other
schools you mentioned before that that
it wasn't the end thing to be before
black power to be a good student or to
be known as a bright student well it's
it was it was interesting um in my
particular neighborhood like it's kind
of hard to explain um it was a
middle-class black neighborhood but the
people who I grew up with their families
were middle class because if their
parents had good factory jobs for the
most part you had a couple people whose
parents were teachers school teachers
but my
to everyone else their parents had good
factory jobs because we're talking about
a time in the Midwest where you had
industrial cities in the Midwest where a
lot of blacks could leave the south come
to the Midwest and get very good jobs
making what what today will be
equivalent of 45 40 45 thousand dollars
a year working in a factory so those are
the kind of kids I grew up with and and
my father was the only one in the
community who was a physician now there
were other black physicians at Fort
Wayne but there none of them lived in
black communities we're the only one to
live in black community so they bathe
most many of the students most of the
kids I grew up with basically you know
there are few of us who get this notion
about black power but we all for the
most part had this idea of the about
this there was a certain way to be black
and we didn't have the idea to the
extent that the kids in the inner-city
part of Fort Wayne headed because they
basically thought of us you know the
folks in inner-city blacks and intercity
basically thought of those of us in my
community which was called Southern
Heights they basically thought of us is
set apart from them because we lived in
nice modest houses so but but for the
most part what still existed among the
people in southern Heights was the
notion that there was a certain way to
be black and it wasn't a notion that
they'd really accepted being
intellectual so it wasn't until I got
into the latter part of June I was
probably ninth tenth grade that I
started like you know veering away from
that me and some other play a few other
handful of other black students
including my sister and maybe three or
four others we started veering away from
that idea and deciding where we're gonna
do well in school no matter what would
you study at Brown I studied a variety
of different things as I was trying to
figure out what I wanted to do for a
while I wanted to be a lawyer at first I
came in wanting to be a writer because I
had won a major high school writing
award was the only one in the in
northeastern Indiana to win it I'm gonna
work called the National Council of
teachers of English achievement award in
writing but I saw my first article
published in a student newspaper at
Brown it didn't look like I hadn't even
written it so that kind of turned me off
to journalism I didn't look like you
ready because the editor had edited so
heavily so well geez this is what it's
all about I don't want to go into this
so I I didn't I just had the idea that
this is something that uh that
I I might not want to do and so from
there I thought about being a lawyer so
I took you know some social science
courses and then eventually I found my
way into pre-med not so much because I
loved the sciences but because I thought
well you know looking back on my father
his life and the fact that he was
independent and very very well respected
I wanted to do something where I could
have an impact on people's lives and
could be independent and make a decent
living you know well you know more than
decent leave a comfortable living so I
went into pre-med I guess I really
started going into it hard and my junior
at brown and actually I took an extra
year I graduated from brown one time but
I took an extra year between finishing
brown and going on to medical school and
finished up my pre-med then in majors in
biomedical ethics which was on an
interdisciplinary major at Brown did you
get a medical degree I know I did I
spent two years in medical school and
left because I figured that eventually I
I figured I wasn't gonna become a good
doctor III my studies I I just lost an
interest in the science of medicine um I
was doing all sorts of things in a Mary
Medical College I was a public relations
director for the Student Health Fair I
was co-editor of the student newspaper I
was getting involved in a lot of
political issues at Meharry and just in
and spending less and less time on my
medical studies and I just decided well
I I'm not gonna be a good doctor so I
decide to leave where do you live down I
live in New York City doing what I'm in
writer from Pacific News Service I've
written articles there's been like the
New York Times a Newsday a variety
different things well for the most part
of the last couple of months I've been
out promoting the book and it started in
writing freelance for you know for other
publications as well as it's doing stuff
for a Pacific News Service how many by
the way how many Panthers were there at
the height of the movement there's those
estimates of for the total number of
Black Panthers very now some people say
there was a couple of thousand at the
height of the movement and it's hard to
get an exact figure because the Panthers
were a national phenomenon roughly from
1968 to 1971 they developed chapters
after Huey Newton was accused of
shooting the police officer in Oakland
they became an overnight sensation for
blacks around the country particularly
blacks low-income blacks so chapters
started sprouting up around the country
and it's hard to get an exact number on
it some people say there were as many as
5,000 too high some people the the lower
estimate goes down to about 1,500 to
2,000 on page 209 of your book you say
that the celebrities such as Harry
Belafonte Dick Gregory Donald and
Shirley Sutherlin Otto Preminger Angie
Dickinson Jane Fonda and others
contributed to the Black Panther cause
why and what was their cause well the
cause was one of it was kind of a
two-pronged thing the the notion that of
taking up arms against the establishment
again like like I said I was saying a
little bit earlier this was a very
common notion back in 67 68 69 that the
establishment was wrong and something
needed to be done about the
establishment you had to overthrow the
establishment and the Black Panthers
were more or less seen as the vanguard
of among people who decided we needed to
take up arms and yes because Huey dude
and say look pick up the gun we have to
pick up the gun so you had a lot of
people like the people you just named
who basically had that deal something
does need to be done about the
establishment so you had on the one hand
that was going through the minds of a
lot of people and the other hand the
Panthers had come up with community
programs by 1969 they were running free
breakfast programs school programs
singer that nature very grass roots
programs also you know from free
clothing free shoe programs things of a
very grassroots nature already at the
money they got the money from donations
from Huey Newton and the Panthers they
basically had a lot of friends and
Hollywood friends in New York who gave
the money to the park like you know like
Leonard Bernstein would throw because
there's there's that very famous party
that Bernstein threw where they you know
got donations for people of that nature
let me read this quote is from Jane
Fonda Revolution as an act of love we
are the children of revolution born to
be rebels it runs in our blood she
called the Black Panthers quote our
revolutionary Vanguard we must support
them with love money propaganda and risk
what year did she say that if I remember
correctly she said it in about nineteen
seventy would she did you ever try to
reach her and see if she would say the
same thing today no I didn't try to
reach her the see she would say the same
thing home they were so there were a
number of different people I wanted to
reach but fond the main reason I didn't
try to refine it because I thought I
would have to go through too many layers
to to reach her cuz I figured she's such
a celebrity yet particularly since she's
married to Ted Turner now I figured you
know why spend time trying to reach
someone like that when I can just look
at what she said back then and tell Ritu
what she said back then what was the
point of quoting her here what did let
people know that you know someone like
Jane Fonda who's beta food basically is
seen as a very well-respected actress
she has a she has a history of having
supported causes that people might not
remember that she supported now which
which isn't to say that someone should
should should see her as an asset
because she did that but to give people
give readers a notion of the the breadth
of support that the Black Panthers had
so at one time one of the things that I
think that a lot of people who've been
revealing my book have not made
potential readers aware of is that the
first hundred pages saw the book I don't
even talk about the Black Panthers I've
talked about the history of the civil
rights movement not even going back to
the 50s but going back to the 20s and
then I bring readers up through the
involvement of young whites because all
of the white student activism of the 60s
came out of the civil rights movement in
the south I mean the you had white
students coming from the West Coast in
the North going to the South
particularly during Mississippi Freedom
Summer and then coming after after
engaging a Mississippi Freedom Summer
coming back to their campuses and
engaging a student activism and after
they were basically following as the
purposes kicked out of the civil rights
movement by black militants then they
started putting their energy into the
anti-war movement so I I'm basically
trying to show people how you
celebrities that we see the icons for
the most part today we're also part of
this movement and I think that a lot of
people should be made aware of the fact
that we're not there was only at a
certain point in the late 60s that we
had people of varying often to this this
separatism as far as as far as blacks
and whites and their attitudes are
concerned now at one time black and
white students black and white young
people were very much into trying to
work together so that I give people an
idea of how Jane Fonda
randal people of that nature were all
part of this you say that some people
wanted money before they talked to you
for this book yeah some people in the
Panther Party wanted money before they
talk because I am I don't I don't like
to give names because mainly because I'm
figure where you know people could
possibly engage in some type of legal
action soon you know sitting for libel
or something of that nature are you at
all afraid about what you wrote could
come back down I'm not I'm not at all
afraid only because I think that um for
the most part most of the people that
I'm speaking of they've moved on in
their in their lives there's people who
are angry about me pointing out the
truth about how the Panther Party was
about more than just some of the
positive things people and remember them
for this plan people are angry about
that but um I don't think there's people
who are out there who are saying well
you know we're gonna engage in some type
of of jihad or something against hew
Pierceton because he's written a book
that that points out some of the things
we don't want to be to have pointed out
Mary Kennedy who is she she was a
rank-and-file member of the Black
Panther Party
oh right her black she's black um one of
the that's another thing like like is
that now that you mention is one of the
things I think people should also be
made aware of is I spend a lot of time
in the book talking about rank-and-file
party members most of the time when
people want to remember the Panthers
people who were in the know of that
about that era they want to remember the
leaders only and what I wanted to do in
the book I own the only leader I really
wanted to focus a lot of attention on
was Huey Newton I wanted to contrast his
life with what from what rank-and-file
members went through in the party so
there's an entire segment of the book
where I give people the notion of what
might have happened they hear about this
Black Panther Party about this party
started by Huey Newton and popularized
by Bobby Seale aknowledge Cleaver they
say well hey I want to join this party
what might it have been like if you are
a woman who decides I want to join this
party or if you're a man who says I want
to join this party and Mary Kennedy was
one of the people I focused on as an
ordinary rank-and-file member that no
one would associate who no one would
associate with the Black Panther Party
in the way you associated Bobby Seale or
just Cleaver Huey Newton with the Black
Panther she's still alive she's still
alive and working and she lives in the
East Oakland at last count in your book
she has eight kids or seven seven or
eight um I can't remember the off the
top my head about I think she has
I came from exactly exact number at the
moment but you say that right in the
middle of her being a black panther and
raising these seven kids then she caught
her husband who was also a black panther
having an affair yeah she did what
helped her what happened was like she
tried to divorce her husband but get
party approval for the divorce and she
ran right smack-dab into the middle of
the misogyny Black Panther Party I mean
basically they there were a lot of
people in leadership positions who
basically had a very misogynistic
attitude towards women and they told her
well you know your your husband doesn't
wanna get a divorce so you can't have it
get a divorce and basically she was the
kind of person who obeyed party policy
said okay fine I can't get a divorce
I'll live with what he's doing I know I
don't have to like it but I'll go on and
move on in the party I mean the way it
was in which it was done was in a very
shocking manner I mean you know using
words that I'm not sure I can use on
television and and and I'm enlightened
readers about a lot of the attitudes
that were very very horrible and very
much condoned by people in the
leadership of Black Panther Party now
and I don't wanna I wanna make clear
that not every single male in the Black
Panther Party engaged in this kind of
behavior but the behavior was common
enough so that if you believed in
treating women in this manner you know
you breed your behavior bad practically
went unchecked did you ever meet hearing
it no I didn't because uh he you know he
died you know before I got out there do
you ever meet Bobby Seale I didn't meet
Bobby Seale I've met his brother I met
wine I tried to contact Bobby Seale
through his brother who spoke for the
entire family three times and said in
refuses to talk about for the book where
is this picture from the picture the the
second pictures right down here well my
picture is from when Huey Newton and
Bobby Seale posed about in 1967 from one
of their first it's one of the first
places where they located their Black
Panther Party headquarters who's Bobby
Seale Bobby Seale was the co-founder of
the Black Panther Party
along with you he knew someone who he
had met in the early 60s when they both
were attending junior college Bobby was
was very much associated practically as
much a show associated with the idea and
emotion and what
Black Panther Party did is Huey Newton
I'd say that there were three people who
stand out in the minds of those people
when they think of the Black Panther
Party Huey Newton Bobby Seale knows it's
cleaver and to a lesser extent
now David Hilliard in Lane Brown because
they had autobiographies that came out
last year David Hilliard had a book last
year now what's what's the difference
between reading his book in your book
well Hilliard I think and what it was
his title when he was with the Panthers
well he was spoiled for a long time he
was chief of staff of the Black Panther
Party
this kind overstating him for a long
time but he was he was chief of staff
for the Black Panther Party in the late
60s while Huey was in jail and Eldridge
after Eldridge fled to Algeria he
basically for a few years took over
running the Black Panther Party now the
difference between David's book in my
book is that David he's candid to a
certain extent but he's not totally
candid about some of the things that
were going on in the party he's not
candid about the criminal activity he
was accused of engaging in like you know
the embezzlement of party funds the the
sanctioning of robberies that occurred
was he ever convicted he was never
convicted no there was this this is the
kind of activity that I uncovered by
talking to people were actually in the
party and also from going over a
testimony from people who were in the
party and getting their numbers it's a
public accusation and the public this
was publicly made if congressional and
Senate hearings are here in Washington
DC as a matter of fact and also people
who are in the party who were never
accused of being informants for the FBI
because that's one another one of the
things practically there's a number of
different people who were part of the
party who defend the party who will tell
you that anything negative disconnected
with the party is because the FBI but
you know send people into the to engage
in the activity and I uncovered plenty
of evidence that shows that the FBI sent
people in to help a process that was
already in in action and I think David
Hilliard is plenty of evidence that I
uncovered talking to X Panthers who are
not who were never accused of informing
and on going over testimony which shows
that Hilliard and people in the
leadership were engaging in activities
that he doesn't even mention in his book
this picture here is of a graduation
ceremony what where was it and this was
in the U at UC Santa Cruz when Huey
Newton was getting his PhD in the
history of consciousness
what do you think of that well I think
that uh there's a lot of people who hold
Huy is an icon who are very proud of the
fact that you got a PhD period and I
think that being proud of Huey Newton
having the ambition to get a PhD and and
you know and stick to getting a PhD I
think there's nothing wrong with that
but as far as the content of the program
I think it's very questionable I don't
think you I think there's plenty of
evidence that Huey Newton never really
studied very hard to get the PhD I think
that the history of consciousness uh so
that's a very the the title is very
nebulous um thing you know I think
person has to wonder what on earth is
history of consciousness and his
dissertation is not the kind of
dissertation that required a lot of
studying all he had to do for the most
part was get his FBI files go through
his FBI files and talk about the history
of the FBI trying to persecute him the
Black Panther Party that passed muster
as a dissertation for him to get a PhD
and I don't think that that shows any
real scholarship you have a the first
picture you have in here is a man named
Dellums CL dellums who is he
co dellums was one of the people who one
of the principal people who helped found
the Brotherhood of sleeping car porters
now the Brotherhood of sleeping car
porters is very important because I
think that it can be pointed to from the
nineteen twenties that can be pointed to
as a principle organization that got the
civil rights movement off the ground um
a philip Randolph was president of the
Brotherhood of sleeping car porters was
for the most part after you had booked
to Washington and then after Washington
WB Dubois Marcus Garvey the next person
who became a prominent national black
figure was a philip Randolph but he did
it he started the Brotherhood of
sleeping car porters with the help of CL
dumps who also eventually became
president of the Brotherhood of sleeping
car porters so I talked about Dells
because Dellums was located in Oakland
and he helped Alfa a fella brenell start
the organization which was a national
organization but I speak of him because
Dellums was a key person that got the
movement role relationship to
congressman rondell he's his uncle was
Ron Dellums ever a black panther
he wasn't he during the height of the
Black Panther Party Ron Dellums had
started his political career and
actually in the early seventies but he
wasn't he was elected congressman from
the Oakland Berkeley area and he did
have some political dealings with a
Black Panther Party he he went in into a
lot of situations and kind of became a
mediator between the Panthers and other
people in the Oakland Brooklyn at
Berkeley area there's a picture in the
book here of a gentleman by the name of
H rap brown people my age remember him
in 1967 started a riot right around here
in Cambridge Maryland right well what
happened was um the by that time the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee had become very militant and
he had been invited to a town the town
of Cambridge from Maryland to speak to a
group of people in the black community
and he basically gave a speech that
condoned the notion that a local school
should be burned so it became a question
of after after the school was actually
burned the question became well did a
tree at Brown speech have everything to
do with the school being burned because
burn now because of the fire department
at Cambridge said well look you know you
had this guy come in give then gives a
speech and the people wouldn't burn down
the school you know he's the one to
blame we're not gonna put out a fire
that the people basically decided to
engage in on their own so atria Brown
had legal problems from then on out he
had to go underground he just and can't
became involved in a very very tangled
legal web and eventually faded out of
the Black Power movement as a result of
it you found you found him alive alive
did you see him I did see him talk to I
talk to him where did you find I found
him he is an imam in a mosque in Atlanta
in a in southwest section of Atlanta
actually yes well I guess you could say
a western section of Atlanta a very very
intelligent man who's quietly wants to
lead his flock and away from the
limelight and he basically told me that
he gave me some some pointers as to
where I should look to uncover some of
the things I want to go through it took
learner to look at in the movement but
he didn't want to talk about the
movement because because I think that
for one thing I think there's a lot of
bad memories he has about it there's
he's talked
about and he's basically said what he
wanted to say and he's and he's headed
in another direction I was very
impressed with him to tell you the truth
like is like he's not a member of the
Louis Farrakhan sect of Muslims he's a
he's a genuine member of the Islamic
faith of course you know there's
different different sects of the Islamic
faith but he he struck me as a very
quiet and assuming man who an
intelligent man as a matter of fact were
you ever shocked by what you learned
very shocked I mean I didn't I did not
go into writing this book thinking I was
gonna uncover the shocking things I
uncovered name a couple um some of the
murders who was murdered um the people
like a Fred Bennett who was a member of
the Black Panther Party know there's
lots there's a lot of speculation as to
why he was murdered some people say that
the Panther start he was an informant
and murdered him others people say that
he got the the wife of a major leader in
the party pregnant who was a murderer as
a result of that where was he murdered
he was murdered in the Santa Cruz
Mountains outside of Santa Cruz
California when it was about in 1971
from him quickly uh the beginning of 71
have they ever caught the person that no
no they didn't I mean there's the there
was a person who was working with as an
undercover agent who helped dispose of
the body he's not the person who
actually planned the murder and engaged
in the murder but while he was working
undercover in in the Black Panther Party
he in order to in order that he'd not be
found out as an undercover agent he did
go along with helping to dispose the
body what else shocked you another
murder in that shock to me that there's
a lot of speculation on it's a murder of
Betty van parent now there's a lot of
murkiness surrounding that a van Betty
van patter a woman yeah who became a
bookkeeper for a little while for the
Black Panther Party now there's a lot of
speculation as to whether or not the
party killed her or you know and and the
people that I talked to just convincing
evidence that she was killed by the
party but there's there's a lot of
controversy surrounding that large you
used to do with the fact that Betty van
patter is white and there's there's a
lot of people who are angry that that
murder is focused on as a possible Black
Panther murder because I said well you
know why why focus on this white
Panther parties being accused of murder
of murdering and no not focus on all the
blacks who were accused of the time the
Panther Party was accused of murdering
so I can kind of understand that but at
the same time I think that that uh that
the number of innocent people like a
like a woman like Betty van patter or
even Fred Ben or anybody who was killed
by the part of our cues of being killed
by the party I think that that I think
that's something that stands out in my
mind is something that the party
should should is something that it shows
the party should not be seen purely as a
revolutionary do-good organization and I
just think that those two murders and
some other murders murders that I didn't
even uncover that I've you know rumors
about murders and though those are the
types of things that the rumors as well
as the hard evidence is so strong that I
that the party should not be seen as
purely the revolutionary Vanguard had a
lot of people on the left and then the
liberal community want to see it as
gangsta rap
I think gangster rap very much grows out
of the image of the Black Panther Party
created for young black men this image
of defiant posturing that that stands
out in particular with Huey Newton
sitting on the throne gun and won't hand
the spear and the other and also with
what Eldridge Cleaver was doing I'll
just cleaver and who was he eldest
Cleaver was the Fort time he was
basically the leader of the Black
Panther Party while Huey Newton was in
jail he was the Minister of Information
and he for about 1968 when Huey Newton
was sitting in jail waiting to go on
trial for the murder from Oakland police
officer cleaver for the most part became
the mouthpiece for the party and also
Bobby Seale but Cleaver was a person
whose initial thing came from writing a
book called soul on ice Sola Nights was
a book that was probably the first
really outrageous book about young black
men who was seen as as what I would say
our nobles the noble savage and bent
aliens know the noble savage image that
I think young black men still suffer
from cleaver talked about raping women
he said well it first he raped a black
woman and then he crossed the tracks so
to speak and started raping white women
he basically in the book
kind of gave a lot of rationales for why
a young black man in my poor community
can turn into a criminal and he was
basically and you had a lot of people a
lot of quicks who are fascinated with
what he said because he could write very
well I mean the things he was saying
we're very disturbing and outrageous and
he started making speeches after he
became a black panther who basically
condone killing judges and things if you
go to court in the end everything come
out the way you want it didn't the
Conservatives endorsed him a few years
ago well he after he came back he will
he fled to Algeria Algeria and uhm came
back to the United States he wins he was
an algerian france for a while he came
back to the United States in 1975 and he
professed he was a new person he
renounced his Black Panther days he
renounced his radical philosophy all
together and he became part of Reverend
Sun Myung Moon Church he became a
conservative for a while so yeah the
Conservatives supported him and I didn't
research I engaged in a lot of research
of all that L achieve engaged in after
he came back in 1975 up to like say
today but yeah he did become a
conservative for a while and he's been
involved in some minor criminal activity
in the last few years what you talk to
him no I didn't talk to him the reason I
didn't talk to him is because of what I
said a little bit earlier um I wanted to
I want to look at Newton and contrast
Newton with the rank people were in the
rank and file because I think that that
a lot of I didn't want to talk to steel
and could get the seal but I think that
one of the reasons is because I did want
to concentrate on what the rank-and-file
members the party did and the other
reason was because I thought that um the
notion that the people who were in the
leaders of the party we're gonna be very
candid about the party was something
that I didn't agree with I thought that
all people who are in positions of
prominence for the most part are just
like most people were in the positions
of prominence for the most part have an
interest in protecting their image so I
felt in writing the book and I want to
talk to the people were the foot
soldiers by the party because it became
quite clear to me after reunion and
beginning my research that there was an
entire side of the story about the Black
Panther Party the rank-and-file members
and what they went through
there was the gist of what the party was
all about what you saw with Huey Newton
what you saw with Bobby Seale what you
saw with LG Cleaver was was a very small
part of what the Black Panther
phenomenon was all about if they were
all public relations people they were
not the foot soldiers you make some
connections in the back of the book
former LA gang member of Cody Scott who
are in the monster that I'm sorry the
moniker monster Cody from LA police
after he brutally beat a man to death
describes in his memoir monster the
autobiography of an LA gang member
the senseless murders of other blacks
which he also engaged in as a member of
LA's eight brave Crips raring that the
what you go on that he's a white
journalist William Broyles I think he's
former editor of Newsweek who
facilitated the publication of Scott's
book is analogous to journalist Bob
Scheer who in 1966 was a facilitator of
Eldridge Cleaver's career did you give
the Broyles Shearer team good marks or
bad marks for facilitating the careers
of these two men
I even Babb give them bad marks because
I think there's a there's a real element
in the society um I hate to use labels
but I would say leftist liberal elements
in American society that has this notion
that there's that the true blacks are
blacks who are who are basically kind of
I'll just be blown by uncivilized and
that they think of people like Master
Cody they think of people like they'll
just cleaver from solo nice as being the
true black people and that when they
when these people write books about how
they engage in their pathological
behavior they really think they're
seeing the true black person and they
are no raw and unfiltered so I think
that a Bob Scheer Bay very much played
in it into that image now I can't speak
for the Bob Shiller who is exist today
but Bob Scheer from that era very much
played into that because of a very
popular thing to play into this notion
of what K my god mean what is blackness
all about and the idea what blackness is
all about this pathology that we in
white America are largely responsible
for so I think that that this thing that
Eldridge Cleaver promoted his book soul
on ice and
and was kind of brought to the surface
by a Bob Scheer is carried over into the
leftist liberal philosophy about you
know black people in general and William
Broyles picked it up and brought it on
in with master Cody and this whole idea
of okay what what is this monster that
we see in South Central LA I mean what
is he all about
let's examine his behavior and so and it
carries over into movies like ministers
society this idea of the blacks not
being responsible to blacks in the
bottom having no real responsibility for
where they are society having created
this this monster and let's examine this
monster and try to figure out what makes
this monster tick so that's exactly
that's what I'm referring to when I when
I can make the sheer Broyles connection
how old are you I'm 36 I'll be 37 next
month are you where you wanted to be in
your life at this point at this point
yeah I'm very much where I want to be um
I've taken a lot of risks stuck to my
guns to take the risks and basically hit
bottom as far as the things that a
person needs to do to you know as a
struggling writer and have come back up
and I'm very much satisfied with what
I've accomplished where do you write I
write it Batman my place in New York
City I live in the Chelsea district in
New York City give a family monument
just my personal family know I'm a
single man a single man who's happily is
dating a particular woman yeah when you
write what time of day do you do it most
of the time I like to write Oh anywhere
from 11 o'clock at night to about 5:00
6:00 in the morning because yeah I can
hear myself think you know there's
there's New York's a very business that
I love Manhattan
very fascinated with Manhattan and um
and the noise really dies down you know
if anywhere from 11:00 to 5:00 I can go
out and in the day and and go into any
practically any community and and be
fascinating and then at night I can hear
myself think or read or work at my room
at my word processing program on my
Macintosh and I really like to work that
time of the of the early morning
how much do you write at night well when
I'm when I'm really going good I might
spend like like five or six hours
working on a piece I I like to write
every day lately I've been so busy doing
and doing a variety of the things I have
riding every single day I've been
catching up on a lot of my reading in
preparation for other projects I want to
I want to engage in but I would say for
the most part I try to get five six
hours worth of writing done I don't know
at least five six days away
who owns the Pacific News Service who
owns there's a essentially question the
Pacific News Service is a consortium of
writers and scholars from around the
country
sandy closes executive editor of
specific news service it puts out about
one story per day I guess a better way
to say it puts out about six stories per
week in a packet to go out to it goes
out to subscribers but also we have
subscribing newspapers like the San
Francisco Chronicle the Baltimore Sun
the Chicago Tribune and they pick up
stories the same way they would an
Associated Press story what's your dream
job myron my dream job would be i'd say
as an independent author who for some
time where maybe for a few years would
be connected with a major newspaper
writing commentaries but ultimately say
when I'm 50 years old a person who whose
is written in fiction nonfiction um
maybe a couple of plays ultimately
that's what I'd like to do what would
you describe your politics of being
today now that's that's a very good
question because I I see myself
independent probably left or right
mmm I really am reluctant to go to
either side I kind of like to take each
issue as they come one of the things
that I'm amazing myself with is the fact
that uh I think a lot of people who are
branded as conservatives are I think
it's worth the while of a lot of folks
to will listen to what they're saying
they I think that a lot of conservatives
are too easily written off as as racist
and I think that a lot of people on the
Left liberal community can be every bit
as raised as anybody who's good who's
identified as conservative times
conservatives I think espouse
philosophies that are more respecting of
black people in the potential black
people then people were seen as liberal
or left
and in writing a lot of the stuff I've
written I've been accused by people a
lot of people of being a neoconservative
conservative you know one of the black
conservatives but I reject that notion
only because I just I just don't like
labels because I think once you accept a
particular type of label then if an
issue comes down the pike you say okay
well this is this is the label I'm I'm
under which I write so let me figure out
what I'm supposed to say per that label
and I don't like to do that I do like to
like just get rid of all labels and
examine what's being said and I think
and again I want to emphasize that I
think that a lot of people branded as
conservatives I you racist my people on
the Left liberal community are not
really cannot really racist I think that
they are engaging in a real effort to
figure out a way to solve some of our
problems and they just believe that you
could you can't do it to the government
you say you grew up with a handicap the
name Huey oh I hated it why I was picked
on and picked on for that name
incessantly have long I just never liked
it I think it sounds funny I never liked
it and Huey Huey noon was the first
person I ever knew who of who who was
seen as a hero with that name him
because it was connected with a cartoon
characters I didn't really like and I
just said well you know I just don't
want to I didn't want much to do with
the name so that's why don't even use it
well here's what the book looks like and
he's on the book you show Hugh Pearson's
all right did people call you here now
oh yeah yeah the shadow of the Panther
it's a book about the civil rights
movement Huey Newton his death and black
power in this country in the last 30 40
years thank you for joining us
Hugh person thank you for having me